exactly I've hired a choreographer so I  give this I don't know what I don't know  what Zoey's doing mister be pretty damn  I'm the hottest round Star Trek beyond  Zachary Quinto and Zoe Saldana are going  head-to-head on Thursdays episode of lip  sync battle I found out how back  prepared for the showdown lip sync  battle coming up with knowit how are you  preparing and what Star Trek be  integrated into the performance I will  say that for my exact not this is no be  taking it lightly I will say Zoe is a  fierce competitor she's also an enormous  d talented performer and dancer  especially which is not my strong suit  so help you throw sorry I would also  like to add that Zack may have hired a  choreographer so I give this I don't  know what I don't know what Zoe's doing  you